[Music]
the oscars aka the biggest night in
hollywood has come and gone and
something tells us this year's award
show will go down in history funny
ladies amy schumer regina hall and wanda
sykes were tapped to host the ceremony
which saw several history-making moments
ariana dubose triumphed as the first
openly queer afro-latina to win an oscar
plus troy kotzer as the first deaf male
actor to be nominated for and to win an
oscar but sadly those moments are sure
to be overshadowed by will smith
publicly attacking chris rock during the
show while rock was presenting the award
for best documentary feature he made a
jab at jada pinkett smith comparing her
to gi jane because of her shaved head
rock's remark immediately earned him an
eye roll from pinkett smith but smith
took it a step further when he got up
walked over to rock and smacked him in
the face rock tried to play everything
off making plenty of people wonder if
the whole thing was a bit but it soon
became all too real after will smith
returned to a seat where he repeatedly
screamed keep my wife's name out of your
[ __ ] mouth the whole fiasco had just
about everyone's jaw dropped for the
rest of the awards show many celebs who
weren't in attendance even took to
twitter to react moments after the chris
rock and will smith incident occurred
the hashtag what just happened started
trending on twitter and several
celebrities chimed in with their
thoughts some took a more lighthearted
tone with the issue comedian john
fugelsang joked that the two actors will
kiss and make up with a new movie
tweeting right now the agents of will
smith and chris rock are sitting at an
oscars after party negotiating the most
lucrative buddy film in history no doubt
wanting to get in on the jokes conan
o'brien tweeted just saw the will smith
slap anyone have a late night show i can
borrow just for tomorrow meanwhile
diedrick bader saw a unique opportunity
arise from the controversial moment
writing as a minor celebrity i feel like
i have 27 to 30 hours to do anything i
want and no one will notice at the end
of the day new york times journalist
dave itzkoff summed everything up nicely
by tweeting i hope everyone has enjoyed
the last oscars ever it's unclear what
the slap heard around the world will
entail for the future of the ceremony
but some celebrities weren't as quick to
make a joke out of the proceedings
comedian kathy griffin wrote that
smith's move just made things dangerous
for comedians she tweeted let me tell
you something it's a very bad practice
to walk up on stage and physically
assault a comedian now we all have to
worry about who wants to be the next
will smith in comedy clubs in theaters
director rob reiner also argued smith
went too far and wrote will smith owes
chris rock a huge apology there's no
excuse for what he did he's lucky chris
is not filing assault charges the
excuses he made tonight were
there were some celebrities who took the
opposite approach to the situation many
like nicki minaj believed will smith was
justified in his actions and was merely
standing up for his wife she wrote you
just got to witness in real time what
happens in a man's soul when he looks
over to the woman he loves and sees her
holding back tears from a little joke at
her expense this is what any and every
real man feels in that instant while
y'all seeing the joke he's seeing her
pain later in the show after the bizarre
altercation smith accepted the award for
best actor for his performance in king
richard on stage he apologized to the
academy and said love will make you do
crazy things
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]